welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about this horseshoes
ring
and specifically how to arrange stone
properly on it
are you ready let's get started
that's starting with the stone that in
the size you want in this case i have
two millimeter stone and if you want to
know how to make the stone i will have
a link on this right top corner here to
show you how to make the stone but if
you just want to use for practice you
can
go on the bottom uh description i will
have a link
for you to sign up a newsletter and you
can download the stone for free
now i wanted to make a ring size let's
go ahead to
set it up for whatever you want in my
case i have 16 millimeter
so um so the radius will be
eight and then that will be my ring size
now we want to see
like what shape of the horseshoes that
you wanted to have
uh basically i want to start it with a
circle and for whatever size you want it
and make sure that this is right it's
the guideline for our stone to
start to work on this so i may want to
move my stone on to
this where the beginning is going to be
i also wanted to
cutting off where this is going to end
so i'm gonna
draw a line see where that whole shoe's
opening is going to be
making a mirror to mirror to the other
side
and using that as my cutting tool to
trim this off
all right so my stone is going to
starting from here
and all the way to the end so once we
have that i want to move this to the
correct position
and to make sure that the stone is close
to where the line
is to start with okay i just trim it a
little bit more open
and next what we wanted to do is we want
to move
uh the stone from make sure that
your vertex is on so we can snap on it i
want to
snap into this vertex and snapping into
this endpoint there so that's where
we are going to start it and we
are going to use the command it's under
the
transform and you have array a long
curve
and then you want to erade this one so
this is the stone you want to array hit
enter and this is the curve we kind of
need to guessing how many they are so
let's guess guessing 10
and it looked nice over there but we
wanted to make sure that the distance is
enough for us to put the prong
now depends on you wanted to have a
shared prong or you want to have
you know each of a stone has a full
prong
we want to measure make sure that the
distance in between here for example
that's roughly snapping here and here
and this is about 0.5 millimeter that is
enough for
having a two prong in between so that is
a good distance for what i have here
once we have that i'm going to building
the rest of the ring so let's go ahead
to making another circle and this circle
i wanted to make sure
is bigger than the stone that we have
because we need to have a little bit
wall there
so i'm going to have roughly something
like this and another one simply just
scale this down a little bit the same
wall size
and then have something like this so
that'll be my wall
okay so let's start in building this
ring it look a little bit stronger
uh wall that i have there because i
always like it
to be stronger so it's easier once
you're casting you can finish you won't
like lose too much of a material
the next things i wanted to do is
creating the oval
and i'm going to snap in here and
depends on what
size do you want it uh how thick the
ring that you're going to have in this
case
you can see i have something like this
is pretty thick
all right so we're going to pick up this
circle and this circle and let's bring
up to the top
for where the ring is going to start it
with
and it need to be over the stone
a little bit so this is the curve that
we have
now let's go ahead to build uh the
bottom ring shank
i'm gonna come over here and i'm going
to uh
using the arc tool snapping into the
zero
snapping into the quadrant here and
quadrant there
i always like to have my ring is a
little bit tapered on the bottom so
just moving the control point up a
little bit so you will get the taper
a little bit on the on the bottom now to
attach
this to that side we can simply just
draw a line
so we can go ahead to draw this line
holding the shift
to make sure that it is it is going up
on that first point
and then we can connecting into this
point
all we need to do is having that profile
if you
like it and mirror to the other side so
we can join all those three together
double make sure they are on the same
plane if they
are not you need to make sure they are
flat to making the surface we need to
sweep this guy so let's go ahead to
split this guy
right in the middle with the point right
there so now i have
two curve there we can look at the
perspective
to making this small like a signal ring
we are going to
using the surface command on the surface
command you got sweep two rail you got
rail one
rail two cross section here and here
don't forget to go into the very last
point
at the quadrant there make sure that
they are in the same
direction and i also want to record a
history so that allow me to do some
changing here so for example if i felt
like this is too
coming down too much i wanted to be
thicker i can move in this one because
the history is on so it will continue to
follow
now if everything looks nice to you you
can go ahead to
click on this surface and using the
command cap
then you will cap this one we can now
using this circle
as a ring size and we want to extrude a
planar curve straight
and we can use a bowling difference
difference this ring out of this ring
size so now we can have this
all we need to do is cutting out the
center right there
so let's go ahead and take a look on the
top view we want to draw a straight line
roughly from here to outside right here
and having that one to mirror to the
other side
okay so i'm going to pick up all those
curve here
and send them to another layer so it's
easier for you to see
and that's just looking at those layers
right here
so we want to make sure they are all
contact
since they are in different high right
now so we are going to pick up all four
curve right here and we are going to use
a command project to c
plane and we want to delete the input so
now
everything is flattened to the seaplane
and we can trim
each other trimming off
the area that we don't want it okay so
now
i'm keeping this one here and i'm going
to make
another curve just connecting this point
and this point for something like that
and join them this is going to be our
new cutting tool
so i'm going to use that to extrude
planet curve straight
i only need on one side so both are
equal
no and make sure you uh have it over the
stone so if we turn it back the ring
that we have
this will be our cutting tool let's go
ahead
to use a bowling difference this out of
this one
and then this is the ring that we get so
i need to cut the opening out
for the stone to show off so let's go
ahead to duplicate it
the age that we have here so you got one
two
three four and
since this is a seam so there's an extra
there five make sure you pick up all of
them
and join them together and i'm also
going to using the offset curve command
and that's offset maybe 0.5 millimeter
going inward so i have a new curve there
okay so with this curve i'm going to
extrude planar curve straight
and we want to go down just a little bit
lower than the girdle so now we have our
cutting tool let's go ahead boiling
different this one
out of this one so now we can see our
stone there it's working with the prong
so i'm going to create a prong
it's about this long
and i'm going to pipe it let's say the
diameter is
0.6 millimeter
and then i'm going to moving this prong
over
here another prong
will be over here make sure that you are
not touching the wall
otherwise it will be hard for setting
there's another one is going to be
here
and this one is going to make a copy
over there
okay so now we have those four one two
three four
we are going to use the same command to
array
a long curve and this is the curve we're
going to array and we want to do 10 of
them the same thing
we might need to do a little bit
adjustment there
because this is touching the the wall so
i'm going to move it out just a little
bit so it's not touching the wall
it may be cutting it too much there i
might need to make this one just
tiny bit smaller and move it outside a
little bit
and for the other side we can simply
just mirror to
the other side there so now we have the
prong
if you like to learn more about song
setting i have
online course talk about all different
type of a stone setting
for 3d modeling check out the link at
the description below
to make it look a little bit nicer is
you can have a bevel edge it's more like
bright cut
when you're setting the stone so i might
wanted to do
maybe point three millimeter
for for it to look like the bright cut
and so we want to do this one this one
and also
this one over there so then if you look
at the render view
it will look nicer with the bright cut
and you can hollow the ring if you like
to to reduce the
weight that will be a horseshoe's design
if you like my video consider to join a
membership
that will give me the ability to create
more video to share with
everybody and there's a lot more tricks
and tips that i show in the membership
program
please like and comment let me know how
you like it
thank you for watching i'll see you next
[Music]
so